la competencia en cannes trajo una
reflexión sobre la condición humana y
una colorida carta de amor al periodismo
y al cine
[Música]
el director ruso kirill serebrennikov
trajo a la cual petrov look la
adaptación a la pantalla grande del best
seller los petrov la gripe etcétera
[Música]
uy
benítez quien dijo ya brilla cuando
entienda para ti
esta película por el foco en una familia
de apellido petrov cuando el padre
contrae una gripe y contamina a su
esposa e hijo la fiebre altera sus
mentes y su percepción llevándoles a una
deambulación llena de alucinaciones
entre sueños y pesadillas como sucedió
con leto en 2018 el resfriado de los
petrov se proyectó en ausencia de su
director jean louis debré niko quien
cumple un arresto domiciliario en rusia
desde hace 4 años
[Música]
la alfombra roja de cannes sirvió el
lunes por la noche con la llegada del
fabuloso elenco de the french this match
del cineasta de culto wes anderson de
franch despache es la historia de un
semanario ficticio y de sus talentosos
periodistas en la también ficticia
ciudad de ovnis ceo clásico
la cinta cuenta como el hijo de un
director de periódico convence a su
padre de crear un suplemento dominical
para narrar historias de los bajos
fondos escritas y protagonizadas por sus
propios reporteros the french dispatch
se presenta como una colorida antología
de historias plagadas de referencias y
detalles una impecable factura visual y
ritmo frenético
wes anderson se rodeó de un ramillete de
superestrellas en esta cinta desde bill
murray hasta benicio del toro pasando
por francés mcdormand tilda swinton
timothée salame en resumen la cinta más
glamorosa y esperada del 2021